SPEAKER: Cloud
storage costs money.
And unless you're
made of money, you'll
want to understand how
to optimize your spending
to match your data
storage and serving needs.
As a fellow human who's
not made of money,
let's talk about those
fees, your options,
and the importance of
budgeting in cloud storage.
[JAZZ MUSIC]
Just like a grocery run
on an empty stomach,
a budget can help you keep
your cloud computing and food
bills from getting surprising.
Let's look at how pricing
breaks down for cloud storage.
To start, cloud storage
pricing is based
on the following components--
data storage, which
is the amount of data
stored in your buckets.
The rates will vary depending on
the storage class of your data
and the location
of your buckets.
Retrieval and early
deletion fees--
those are applicable
for data stored
outside of standard
storage classes.
And network usage-- the amount
of data read from or moving
around between your buckets.
Operations usage are the actions
you take in cloud storage,
like listing objects
in your buckets.
And remember, there are four
different storage types,
and the less frequently
you access that storage,
the less you pay to store it.
Cost for all four is
based upon at rest
per location, which is a fun
way of saying the cost is
determined by where the
data lives when it's
just chilling in storage and not
where it's actually being used.
For standard storage,
the monthly cost
is the only cost you
need to plan for.
However, with the other
three storage types,
you'll want to consider the
minimum duration of that data,
as well as any retrieval costs.
For example, coldline storage
has a minimum storage duration
of 90 days and a retrieval
cost of, say, two pennies.
So the cheaper monthly
cost is completely worth
it if you only want to access
this data about twice a year.
If, however, you find
yourself accessing or updating
the data every
week, you'll end up
spending more money
than if you had selected
standard storage to begin with.
When discussing
network costs, we also
need to distinguish
between egress and ingress.
Egress represents the data
sent from cloud storage,
like when reading
data, and ingress
represents the data sent
to cloud storage, like when
writing data.
Network ingress is always free.
For network egress, there are
three categories to consider.
First, when that network
egress is moving or copying
data to other cloud
storage buckets,
or when other Google Cloud
services access that data,
this is considered network
egress within Google Cloud,
and is free within regions such
as reading data in a US East
1 bucket into a US
BigQuery data set.
Pricing then applies for
egress between regions
or across continents.
Second, if you use certain
Google Cloud network products,
such as Cloud CDN or
Cloud Interconnect,
egress pricing is based
on their pricing tables.
All other egress is considered
to be general network usage
and is built based upon which
continent the data is traveling
to.
The fourth factor to consider
with billing is operations.
Operation charges apply
when you perform operations
within Cloud Storage.
To clarify, an
operation is an action
that makes changes
to or retrieves
information about buckets
and objects in Cloud Storage.
Operations are divided
into three categories--
Class A, Class B, and free.
For a full list
of the operations
that fall into each class,
check the documentation.
As a brief overview,
Class A includes creating
storage buckets and objects.
Class B includes
retrieving storage objects.
And free operations are
primarily deletions.
To build your own budget
with accurate cost estimates,
check out the
Pricing Calculator.
And for more information
or to see specific costs,
please be sure to check out
the documentation linked below.
Having a budget
will help you plan,
as there's so much more that
you can do with Cloud Storage,
but that's all for
another episode.
Subscribe, give
us a Like, and let
us know what features
of Cloud Storage you'd
like to learn more about.
Thanks for joining us for this
quick bite of Cloud Storage.
[JAZZ MUSIC]